thank you guys so much for doing this um
really my first question is just um you
know it's been
almost six months since what happened
how are you guys as a family
doing um and what are you leaning on to
kind of get you through what's happened
[Music]
um we're still like you know it's hard
because
we well it's still hard like we're still
going through it
that you know um we're like holding up
but there's some times where like you
know it's
more tough because we just you know um
we always think about her all the time
like there's not a day
you know that goes
right um and just before i continue it's
asking me to
i'm trying to record and it's uh telling
me that i need the host's
permission to record yes let me
do that hang on thank you so much i'm
sorry about it
no it's okay
okay perfect um my next question is you
know how did you all hear about the
arrest
um and and kind of did that bring you
any closure
um we we got
a phone call that like
that's pretty much how we heard about it
and then yeah it did give us closure
like a little bit
yeah um when you found out about the
arrest i mean what was the family's
reaction
we were very happy um
but then i get sad because you know
nothing
that doesn't bring back my sister
nothing will ever bring back my sister
and you know like
it's uh one step forward
getting the justice uh you know nothing
will ever move them back
even though we catch them yeah
uh and then knowing that you know the
person responsible or you know that that
played a role in this is still on the
loose
uh if if you could if your family could
send a message
to him right now what would that message
be
um to just
turn yourself in because there's
no way of hiding out anymore you can't
hide
and just you know pay for what you did
because we're never we're not gonna stop
until we get justice
very good was there anyone else who uh
wanted to ask a question or should i
continue or
um uh ricardo went to las vegas
um i was wondering if i could uh ask to
the mother araselli
[Music]
familiar
foreign
is
family
is
will one of the daughters mind just uh
translating just uh if
just very briefly uh what you just said
if you don't mind i'm so sorry
you're fine
she said that um
she wants you know like
these past few months like it's been
hard for our family
um they took like
a daughter that was you know very
special to her
away from our family and
you know she wants justice and she wants
eric to pay for what he's
what he has done because nothing will
ever bring her back to us
and that you know every
every day she thinks about her not a day
goes by that she doesn't and
you know like the the only thing that
she wants right now is for justice and
for
eric to pay for what he has done
thank you so much you're welcome thank
you
anybody else uh yes this is rafael
contreras with univision nevada do you
hear me okay
yes um if i can
ask another question in spanish for
univision
[Music]
moment
family
mexico
[Music]
did you ask whether he was in mexico
eric
or what is that what you asked uh yes
this is
uh raphael with univision that was the
last question yeah
okay i think we lost them
um yeah i think we lost a family
okay we'll just wait till they log on
but i do want
to comment on that and say that we don't
want to narrow
our search for eric to place mexico
we definitely want to search for him
everywhere in california
could be in texas could be in mexico
could be
in nevada we just don't know
great thank you so much for that um
that's all for univision
if anyone else wants to jump in
um sorry
this is alejandro conde frontelemundo um
do you know do you have any update in
the coroner's report
after six months no no report from the
coroner's office yet we are still
waiting
and the matter the cause of death is
still unknown
why could this be taking so long to you
know figure out exactly what happened
we don't know because it is an open
murder case
it might be taking long
we just don't know why it could be
because of coved we really don't know
yeah has police uh spoken to the family
and kind of given them a little bit more
of an idea of what could have happened
or what the probable cause for arrest is
we do know what the probable cause for
arrest is
but we don't really know what happened
as to details we don't know
what caused leslie's death we don't know
what caused eric to
kill her to murder her and have his
father
help him and try to get away with it
we just we don't know but we're hoping
that with this
arrest of jose and having jose in
custody
that we'll be able to get some of our
answers
that we've been looking for for months
now um
what was your reaction to knowing that
this father
um you know however this happened that
this father helped his son
cover something so heinous up versus
holding him accountable i mean what does
that say and
and what should be taken away from this
situation
i am just i'm shocked i can't i can't
believe this
you know not only did the father just
not
say anything he helped him you know
there is evidence
to show that jose helped eric drag
leslie's lifeless body out of their
house
um you know the video shows of jose
helping
her helping eric put her body in the
pickup truck
and jose stayed while eric drove
leslie's body to valley of fire
jose stayed home and cleaned up the mess
he
covered up the crime i'm just
i'm speechless i i cannot believe
somebody would do
that and we you know we saw the press
release but
those details that you just released um
this is really the first time we're
hearing those
how did who has that video and how did
you get access to that information is
that in the arrest report or
i can't comment on where the video came
from
but it is from the grand jury indictment
okay very good i mean
you know on behalf of the family i'm not
sure if you know they lost their
connection um
what is the the message here again i'd
just like to ask
what would you say if this second
suspect
somehow sees this uh what would you say
to him
i'm sorry gabby can you say that again
cut off
uh sorry about that i was just saying
you know just one more time i mean what
is the the the message from the family
uh to eric about you know turning
himself
in just what would the family like to
say if he were somehow to see this
uh who they want to you know see him
turn
himself in um it's very disappointing
for the family to see
that somebody that they have trusted and
have known for so many years
um could do something like this to their
sister to their daughter
um they just want some answers
they they're just they can't wait to see
eric in custody and we're very very
hopeful
that soon we'll be able to see that
very good um have police said anything
about um
i know you said you don't know where
exactly he is but have they said whether
the the father is cooperating yet or is
it kind of too soon to know if he's
gonna talk
yeah we just don't know yet we have no
idea um
i just don't know we hope that he will
we hope that this time he will do the
right thing
and he will cooperate with the
investigators and the detectives
and the prosecutor and lead us to
eric forever
i'm sorry and my final question is just
you know
once eric is caught or you know is is
him being caught really
what it is going to take to let this
family
move forward and really begin to begin
to heal do you think
you know i can't comment on that but i
think it would be
a major safety
net for them you know they have to look
over their shoulder
every time they you know walk out of the
house
you know it's not a good feeling knowing
that somebody who murdered your
sister or your daughter is still
somewhere out there and
is not in custody and
sorry danger sorry
it's okay
hi sorry we lost you guys there um
i guess my final question to you all
would just be you know um
what ha you know when eric is caught
um do you think that and i just asked
ophelia this as well do you think that
is
going to help you guys to kind of start
healing and
processing this better is the fact that
that guy's still out there kind of
stopping you guys from really finding
that closure
um yeah i think it would like it
wouldn't make things fully better
but it would help a little bit because
knowing that he's out there you know it
makes stuff like
a little bit more worse so
i think it'll probably just give us
closure and peace
if like it gives god
uh and just knowing that this is a
question that um if you guys could
um maybe ask your mother for me i mean
you all told me when i interviewed you
in the past that
um eric had been a friend of the family
for at least 16 years i think
i was told um how do you process the
fact that someone that that you know you
trusted is now on the run
for for such a heinous crime uh and and
just kind of what are her feelings about
that
[Music]
[Music]
she said that he had no right to do that
that it's devastating to know
how we've known this family for a long
time and
um oh i'm sorry
[Music]
okay can you hear me yes i can that's
okay okay
um she said that um it's devastating
that we've known this family for a long
time
and that they would do something like
this because we trusted them and
and like it's just like really
devastating he had no right to
to tell you to do that to her like in
any way possible
and did you all know his father as well
did your mom know his father
you know she never knew him
only the mother thank you
um i think we'd like to say that you
know we're relieved
to see that jose is in custody
but we also feel like there's a major
gap you know
to fill the rest of this in order to
get some kind of closure and that is the
capture of
eric rangel i think that it's important
that we don't stop here
and we keep looking for eric
because he is the main suspect
and it's really a major threat
and a danger to whoever
eric's around
we encourage everybody you know to share
this leslie's story
and spread the word um jose has
a preliminary hearing actually coming up
his hearing is tomorrow during the
hearing the judge will decide whether
there's enough evidence
to request a trial and
then the case would get bound over to
district court
so tomorrow he has a hearing so we'll
see how that goes and we're very hopeful
that there's tons of evidence to link
jose to the crime
thank you guys thanks for caring i
wanted uh i wanted to ask you if uh you
were uh connected to the family before
this happened
and if not uh what have you learned
these past uh six months about uh
about leslie and um i mean i guess the
case
um sorry
i'm sorry i've briefly known the family
prior to the case um but i've definitely
learned a lot
more about the family and i
learned that they are just
amazing people they're very very
faithful
they're very positive and i'm just
i couldn't imagine being in their
position and going through what they're
going through and feeling what they're
feeling
by losing their child
they definitely did not deserve this
they're very strong they're very strong
and i know that they're gonna pull it
together and i know that we're gonna be
very strong together
to make sure that there is some kind of
closure and definitely justice in this
case
thank you and this is alexis ford with
the review journal um i have a question
for the family i know you said
um you know that it's it's a relief to
see the arrest of jose
but you also want to see this
arrest of eric and you want to see him
be captured and
to see these men pay for what they did
and to see justice
for leslie so what i guess what
repercussions are you hoping to see
these men face after their arrests
i would say a life in prison if not
yeah without the possibility of parole
for both of the men
very good um thank you so much for your
time i think a channel three uh
uh got what we needed and and thank you
to the family so much i'm very sorry for
what you all are going through um
and hopefully you guys can get that
justice that you're looking for thank
you gabby thank you there's anybody else
ophelia uh do you think in the future
the police is going to press charges
against the mother and the sisters of
eric because supposedly
they were at the house at that time
um i'm not i'm sorry you cut out can you
repeat that please
if you think in the future the police is
going to press
charges against the mother and the
sister of eric
i am not sure i can't comment on that i
i don't know
if they were involved in it i would say
they should definitely be prosecuted
for their involvement in such a hideous
[Music]
crime
anybody else
nobody else has any questions i think we
can
finish off thank you thank you
thank you so much thank you thank you
guys
thanks everyone